i'm ainsley earhart i'm brett baer i'm
katie pavlich and this is the fox news
rundown
friday may 27th 2022 i'm lisa brady
they're not invisible wounds of war
anymore today you'll meet the warrior
couple helping veterans take that first
step toward healing and that's really
critical is
people like tom stepping up and saying
hey war affected me but i can get to the
other side of it and the more people
that share that the less people feel
alone in it and it's critical i'm chris
foster the actor gary sinise is back as
host of the national memorial day
concert at the capitol we want
not only the national memorial day
concert
to remind everybody and and of the
sacrifices that have been made by our
fallen but we want them to know that
sacrifices have been made by many of our
living veterans and that we should reach
out and touch them and help them
and i'm tom chalu i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
one of america's most elite warriors
someone who led countless high-profile
missions including the capture of saddam
hussein as part of the army's delta
force remembers vividly the day he
nearly took his own life gun in hand i
remember feeling very very sad
but very calm
[Music]
and then i got more and more terrified
because i knew i was going to do it but
retired command sergeant major tom
satterly eventually answered one of many
messages from jen who's now his wife
putting his gun away that day in 2013
and later beginning a new kind of
mission to help himself and other
veterans he tells the story in a fox
news digital originals feature also
explaining the moment during an infamous
firefight in somalia when he thinks his
complex ptsd began i just dropped a
grenade on somebody was crawling up on
me to try to kill me the gunfire was
outside was getting louder and louder
and my teammate popped in
and you could hear the convoy trying to
make it to us with all the gunfire going
off and i asked them like are they going
to make it
are they going to get to us and you know
his answer was i don't know i mean turn
around left satterly says he figured
then that he would die and he calls it
the switch that flipped him into the off
position but after surviving life became
a battle a struggle he willingly shares
in the hope of saving others i think
it's the absolute
[Music]
definition of our foundation i didn't
study it i lived it i fought through it
and it wasn't easy tom and jen together
created the all secure foundation it was
multiple modalities of healing that
took multiple years that is ongoing to
this day so
we we actually do it we film it we push
it out and people see that it's not so
scary and then they reach out and ask us
about it and then they go do that
modality of healing so yeah it was kind
of imperative to
to our mission
so i started off with anger management
that was number one it was like what's
my biggest problem was it anger you know
so i i started off with that
which led to oh you're not an alcoholic
you're a problem drinker and oh this can
stop and you have post-traumatic stress
and i'm like well the army said i didn't
so you know i don't know if i agree with
you or not and i was defensive of that
but that led to another modality of
healing of transcendental meditation
which led me to tms transcranial
magnetic stimulation which led me to
stellar ganglion block shot which
each one of those
took off a heavy blanket of
something the heavy weight that held me
back from other things and allowed me to
do more work of counseling
that's a lot to
take on
and also to unpack at the same time that
may sound
like so much to anyone who's just having
trouble even taking that first step
to ask for help but
i guess part of the point is look
there's not
one problem and there's not one solution
right and this multi-faceted approach
can maybe succeed where other approaches
have failed
100 this is not a there's not a shot or
a pill that we have found
that treats pts it takes multiple years
and multiple modalities of healing and
like you said every single person on
this planet is different so it's going
to show up differently and people need
to attack different things first
i want to back up to
the way you come at this from different
perspectives as a couple
because
tom's decorated service career included
surviving what became known as black
hawk down in the movie
and jen had actually started to notice a
pattern working as a filmmaker and
photographer embedded with special
operations forces on training missions
is that combination of perspectives is
that what's led to a different approach
in your programs
i think so i was definitely a fish out
of water and
and so for me i was approaching
something that was very normalized to
them this was just who we are we're
warriors and i think being a total
outsider to the community i was able to
see some things that maybe when you're
in the thick of it you can't so i
absolutely think that
both of us together have
well you got a rare spouse view as well
right behind the lines underneath the
curtain whatever you want to say and
that's what a lot of spouses are jealous
of
this your mistress is this military
thing that you do that you love so much
and we're left behind
she got to see what we do and have that
understanding that that connection of
hey spouses i know what's going on and
you're not crazy it's what she tells
them you're not crazy it's normal to
feel the way you feel
a lot of layers there though on both
sides for sure
you do focus on combat veterans and
special operations right did you feel
there weren't enough options for these
types of veterans or there weren't
enough effective options
yes and yes
you know i think there's there's a ton
of organizations that are doing
incredible work we partner with a lot of
them this is an all hands on deck
situation that we're in special
operations operation tempo had increased
so much through the war that we were
just seeing really high numbers of
people suffering and frankly it's the
community that tom was raised up in and
the community i worked in as well so
that's where our familiarity and our
family was
we've never turned anyone away that's
called you know and well i'm not special
ops butt or i'm a cop but
but what hamstrings is are the finances
runs out at some point so we have to
stop it you know at a group of people
that we know we can affect
these service members are trained to be
such warriors
as you were tom as as you are a warrior
on multiple levels now but you talk
about feeling worthless
before you came so close to taking your
own life
is that feeling one of the common
denominators
for veterans who need help
i've found that to be true is the loss
of hope the loss of a tribe a combined
driven goal in one direction and they
get out and they don't understand this
the looser environment of the civilian
world so they we hate what we don't
understand or we fear it so we say we
hate it
but yeah it was it's um yeah worthiness
and unworthiness is probably what we
hear most and for a community that's so
tough and so strong you would think it's
quite the opposite it was surprising to
me when i you know started working
alongside special operations just this
really intense drive for perfectionism
i think that feeling of not being loved
or worthy comes from not loving
ourselves or feeling worthy when we're
not doing that thing we were trained to
do so it's just kind of a single-minded
lost thought process that needs to be
opened up and expanded that there's more
out there to do
one of the things all secure foundation
does i know is work with the family
and something i'd never heard before
turning post-traumatic stress
into post-traumatic growth
which sounds very liberating but also
daunting
yeah it is you know
you grow through adversity you truly do
and those that are brave enough to face
this injury because it's an injury you
can see it it's no longer the invisible
wounds of war we know you can heal from
it there is a side to the other side of
this and you could get there but it is a
task and it's not always easy but it's
worth it
i think a good way to look at it is time
will pass regardless and if you do
nothing your post-traumatic stress will
get worse
so you can do something during that time
you're going to get to the other side of
it how do you want to feel on this side
of it
and is that ultimate goal that
post-traumatic growth that's sort of the
end game it is it is the acceptance of
my past is my past
it's in the rearview mirror which is a
lot smaller than the windshield of the
car so i need to look out the bigger
windshield and in the direction i'm
going if you live in the past too long
that's just kind of where you die and
stay
how do you make these things happen i
know we've talked about different
modalities but how do you make this
happen do you have retreats do you have
other activities with family members do
you do some solo things and some with
family is it it's kind of a mixture
it is in fact we have our retreats
coming up
starting in two weeks we do those with
special operation combat couples
we do coaching every single day that's
the bulk of what we do we do that with
several licensed clinical social workers
and so they're going to enter into a
pretty intensive
program where we're going to assess and
try to help you find your best path
forward because like i said everyone's
unique everyone's path might look
different so we really want to treat the
individual and the individual family
memorial day is a time of tribute of
course i imagine it could be difficult
though for a veteran struggling with
these issues especially if
they've lost people they served with or
if they're having a lot of trouble with
civilian life
i want everyone's focus to be
on the life that they would want you to
live those friends that we've lost
i look at it if i lost my life i would
not want my friends sad every year i
want that party every year memorial day
i want you to remember my life remember
me say my name
but remember i would want you to live
not live sadly the rest of your lives
you know mourn go through the process
and then move on and remember
i know you've helped thousands of
veterans already
how many years has the foundation been
around now and do you feel like
the effort to raise awareness
is breaking through are there more
veterans willing to ask for help
100 there is we were founded the
research part of it was 2016. we became
a 501c3 in 17. however i started working
with tom in 13. so really it's just been
research all along the way
but i will tell you in 2013 to where we
are today
it is getting better and there are more
resources and more people stepping up
and more people sharing their story
saying hey me too and that's really
critical is people like tom stepping up
and saying
hey war affected me but i can get to the
other side of it and the more people
that share that the less people feel
alone in it and it's critical
what do you say to someone who is
resisting
taking that first step what's your
message to them or to those who love
them
i talk about the ten thousand pound
phone it's hard to pick it up you don't
want to pick it up a lot of people pick
it up when they're drinking but then the
next day when they're sober they don't
so
i get that self-awareness that you're a
warrior if you want to claim that you're
a warrior you're a fighter then don't
don't stop here keep fighting never stop
fighting right the day i stop fighting
will be the day that i die and then it's
just because i can't fight any longer
but i'm going to continue to fight for
what i know is good for my family and
for me and that's what i want those
words to do as well have that
perspective and self-awareness that
you're doing nothing by laying there
feeling sorry for yourself get up and do
something there's always someone that
will help you
how can people help your mission and the
all-secure foundation
i think there's a lot of ways to give
back and each and every person has a
unique gift and talent so we always
encourage people to come forward and
share your ideas with us how can you
help in what ways do you want to support
us is it through your talents and your
gifts or your business or through a
donation or through you know sharing
your story so there's many many ways you
can give back to this community and it's
as simple as reaching out to us and
letting us know how you want to give
back i think the best way is also to be
more curious and less judgmental about
what you see
right sit and listen
instead of judgment up front listen and
understand what people go through and
they're just looking to feel better as
well
absolutely is there anything you think
is missing from the broader conversation
nationally or even globally about
this issue of veterans who need help
veteran suicide the whole broad spectrum
of it
i think we need to realize it takes time
you know here in america we want it now
we want that pill we want the shot we
want it now now now we don't have the
patience for it it takes a long time to
get to feel this way it's going to take
a long time to change back to a
different pattern we focus on behavioral
change because those those behaviors
have become muscle memory the aggression
the violence that we don't realize that
we do
until someone points it out you're like
oh well now it takes me time to work on
reversing that and changing them being
someone else and
as we fail along the way we need to get
back up and keep going because it just
takes time so just be patient with it
and be diligent well you're certainly
both warriors and
just thank you for everything you're
doing for all the warriors of the world
because it means a lot it seems like you
know there's good progress so it's great
to hear about so many people being
helped people can find out more at all
securefoundation.org
absolutely that right yes tom and jen
satterly thanks again thanks for
spending some time with us and go to
foxnews.com
to listen thank you thank you thank you
very much
[Music]
this is tom chalu with your fox news
commentary coming up
gary sinise has been in and directed
dozens of movies tv shows and plays he's
won an emmy tony a golden globe and
screen actors guild awards and was
nominated for an oscar for his role as
lieutenant dan taylor and forrest gump
but tom hanks i told you if
you were ever a shrimp boat captain
that i'd be your first mate well here i
am i am a man of my word
okay
yeah but don't you be thinking that i'm
gonna be calling you sir that's from
paramount pictures in 1994 his work with
veterans through the gary sinise
foundation has earned him more awards
than the acting and a lot of gratitude
since 2006 he's been co-host of the
national memorial day concert in
washington they're going to be
you know some changes because we're
coming out of this pandemic no big crowd
still but after two years of being
recorded it's a live show from the
capitol airing on pbs and streaming on
youtube sunday night may 29th at 8 pm
eastern we're very excited to be back on
the stage in front of the capitol as we
always were got a great lineup of
performers again this year
great segments uh i i think it'll be a
dynamite show as it always is they the
capital concerts people really do a just
a superb job in putting it together and
joe and i are very excited to be back of
course yeah on the west lawn of the
capitol usually you get you know half
million people but i guess the big
crowds uh they're just not ready for
that yet um
one thing the concert has this year is a
tribute to general colin powell he died
in october he was a he was a friend of
the concert he spoke a few times there i
assume you knew him at least a little
bit no he was he was part of the concert
going back to the beginning i mean
colin
never missed a show i mean not
i don't think he ever missed a show from
going going back to the beginning and it
was always wonderful to see him he's
just a genuinely wonderful person a
great leader obviously
and very well spoken i mean he he would
he would not even rehearse he'd just
come out there and do his thing
and he was always really really good at
communicating what what he wanted to say
and
we're going to miss him we're doing uh
of course we're doing a wonderful
segment uh to honor him and he he's
always been such a big part of the show
and
it'll be different uh not having him
there
yeah you know i'm glad they're they're
doing a special tribute to him yeah the
actor dennis hayes the great actor
dennis hayes is going to
handle that tribute there's also a
tribute this year to everybody who died
or served in southeast asia during the
vietnam war
it struck me the very youngest of those
veterans that turned 65 this year i mean
talk about the community there is it
still is it still strong
yes i i think so very much i mean um
one one thing
i do a lot of events throughout the year
with my foundation
and some so many over the years so many
of our events
are
attending you know the patriot guard
riders are always there and so many of
them are vietnam veterans who are have
dedicated their lives now to ensuring
that
our returning iraq and afghanistan
veterans
get the support they need because they
didn't receive that when they came home
and i i have vietnam veterans in my
family
a lot of
a lot of the work that i'm doing today
is probably motivated by what happened
to our vietnam veterans way back when i
was
i just missed the draft
i graduated high school in 1973 that's
when combat operations ended in vietnam
but my i met my future wife and she
introduced me to her brothers they were
vietnam veterans her sister
was in the army and married a vietnam
veteran so uh i'm i'm motivated a lot by
trying to ensure that what happened to
our vietnam veterans when they came home
just doesn't happen again
we can never turn our back on our
service members they're they're
volunteers
you know so many of them were drafted
and they
they didn't
necessarily want to go off and fight a
war in southeast asia but they did
and then they came home and they were
treated badly spit on and
the country turn its back on them and uh
we have to we have to do everything to
remember
and remind our citizens that uh you know
whether you agree with the war or not
these are our defenders and we have to
take care of them
uh people watching the concert you're
gonna learn about a military family that
lost two sons and one was lost in iraq
uh killed by an explosion improvised
explosive device one was an rotc cadet
who lost his battle with depression do
you feel like mental health needs have
been more out in the open
for veterans since you started getting
involved with vet causes all those years
ago
yes i i do and there's a you know
there's a lot of focus on it i i don't
think
enough but um i i know a lot of people
that are focused on this we have mental
wellness
initiatives at the gary sinise
foundation uh where we're focusing on
sending
many of our afghanistan and iraq
veterans uh
into retreats and and various clinics uh
wellness clinics that we have that and
that are offering services
free of charge
if somebody needs them you know any
veteran listening
who feels like
maybe they could use something uh you
can go to the gary sinise foundation
website garysony's foundation.org
and reach out to us we want them to know
and every year
we on the national memorial day concert
we do
make announcements to all our veterans
and if you're
you know feeling
lost or alone
there are places that you can turn for
services and we want so we want
not only the national memorial day
concert
to remind everybody and and of the
sacrifices that have been made by our
fallen but we want them to know that
sacrifices have been made by many of our
living veterans and that we should reach
out and touch them and help them
uh speak on the foundation you guys just
moved to tennessee was that some place
you wanted to be personally or was there
a practical
decision i i decided to
[Music]
move the family and you know i asked my
wife and she was
into the idea and then then i went to my
daughter who's got three grandbabies and
said if i
wanted to move to
some place like
nashville would you would you want to do
that because we wouldn't leave without
the grand babies sure the family and my
daughter was
all over it she loved the idea
so they're actually there now we're
still uh you know we're we still have
quite a bit to finish up here in
california but the foundation uh offices
are under construction there
and a lot of the team is
up
and running and
in nashville right now we'll get there
eventually
i see you've got surprise with the new
lieutenant dan van the other day not
your you know regular grocery ride it's
for you know to get best to events and
things like that but it's pretty sweet
it's a nice wrap
yeah well we have uh
our san diego chapter here we have we
have a couple of chapters and we're
opening chapters around the country
uh one chapter in florida one chapter in
in san diego right now and that van kind
of lives with the chapter folks in in
san diego we have a you know it's a big
military community there
i've been going down there for years
doing things and the foundation has done
many things and continues to do many
things in fact just the other night we
had
1200 marines at marine corps air station
miramar
in the bob hope theater there
where we hosted
them for dinner and the screening
of top gun maverick i think they they
might be
some of the first people to see the the
new uh tom cruise movie
so and they were just thrilled and we
lifted them up and the lieutenant dan
van was there and they were taking
pictures with it and
it's uh it's something that's going to
be um
part of that community yeah i see the
lieutenant dan band has a few dates
booked this summer anything new in the
settlers do you mix it up over the are
there songs you hear and you feel like
learning and playing on stage or do you
just kind of stick with what you got
well we know about 80 songs we can only
play about 22 of them we usually play a
two-hour show
it's about 22 songs
um and we know you know so we draw from
a lot of tunes that we played in the
past and then occasionally
uh when we have the rehearsal time we
will you know learn some new things and
and throw them in we're always doing
that kind of thing mixing it up a little
bit but there are certain certain songs
that are always in our show and they're
just part of the show well gary i'll let
you go of mice and men by the way 30
years ago
this year you directed starred produced
is the first time i saw you i assumed
that's a lifetime ago for you right
30 years geez
uh yeah you're right you're exactly
right in fact right around now 30 years
ago i was at the khan film festival in
france with malkovich and
uh and uh alan land uh junior of mgm and
we were all over there and we had a big
screening it was it was a great great
night and then the movie opened
in october of 92. you're right geez
uh gary sinise co-host in the last year
well
i i if you hadn't realized it maybe i'll
send you on a nostalgia trip uh today uh
gary sinise co-host of the national
memorial big concert sunday night 8pm
eastern on pbs streaming on youtube gary
good to talk to you thanks
thanks so much
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand fox
news radio on the fox news app download
it today
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
it's that time of year when students don
their caps and gowns and march across
stages across the u.s picking up their
diplomas and posing for photos
proud friends and family members gather
to watch this process play out in
crowded gymnasiums auditoriums football
fields and arenas cheering loudly for
their graduate despite the pleas to hold
applause to the end i recently sat in
one of those crowds and i was quite
intrigued by the decorations some of the
grads had adorned their mortarboard hats
with you know the square graduation hat
with the tassel
graduation day for the southwest
tennessee community college class of
2022 was held outside at the liberty
bowl memorial stadium in memphis
tennessee and from the stands you could
see hats with feathers some with bright
colors flowers you name it so when the
last degree had been awarded i set out
to talk to those grads with the creative
hats can you describe what's on your hat
for me it's like feathers and diamonds
only
because it matches my dress i became an
rn so it has rn on it and then i work
for imcu with pediatrics i put what what
specialty i'm working on
ptk for honors
so um it's the international honor
society it says i gotta take it off the
scene i know it's a be kind and be
humble okay it says she turned her cans
into the can and her dreams into plans
why did you pick this the same thing
because i've been struggling throughout
the whole you know school semester and i
just feel like i had turned
everything around by just going to
school
and you did it yes i did so i'm a
forensic biotechnician so i have a cold
i mean closed case and then there's
caution tape
nevertheless you persisted and why did
you pick this sand
because it was a long and
circuitous journey to this moment
how many years has it taken you
i started at state technical institute
at memphis in 1990.
you did it tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind
getting ready for memorial day weekend
we're outside it's nice weather
and
i just think i might not be qualified to
talk about memorial day
i mean what do i know i used to go to
the memorial day parade as a kid that
was the sad one you know we always had
the parades in my hometown in norwood
massachusetts we had the fourth of july
parade
we had the
st patrick's day parade
then there was the sad one it was more
somber it ended at the cemetery
and we saluted the troops but
i never served in uniform my
father-in-law did though anthony
belvedere tell me
anthony belvedere
i think you served in germany is that
right yes i did
now you were over there did you go over
by boat by plane how did you get there
we went over by boat 10 days across the
north atlantic
ended up in bremerhaven germany
and i served 19 months in germany and i
was an army medic listen i just poured
him a beer
anthony belvedere thank you for your
service thank you very much thank you no
thank you
i'm tom chalu
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on fox foxnewspodcast.com
or wherever you download podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes